[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Бессарабія,
Утконосівка]
Приходжу я зранку,
заходжу до теплиці й кажу:
«Доброго ранку, помідори!
Як вам ночувалося?
Як вам тут?»
Кожного дня я тричі їх про це питаю.
А як інакше? З ними потрібно розмовляти,
[Євгенія Кіру
Жителька Утконосівки]
якщо хочеш, аби виросли нормально,
щоб урожай був хорошим.
Потрібно розмовляти з рослинами,
якщо ти чекаєш від них хорошого.
Спочатку хотіли будувати
там, на краю села.
Але інші літні люди наполягли
на будівництві на березі лиману.
Тоді вони почали з перцю,
капусти — помаленьку.
Возили врожай до Молдови візками.
І так уже впродовж
60-ти або 70-ти років.
Чотири рази на тиждень
нам дають воду,
а ми двічі на тиждень
поливаємо город.
У кожного є своя свердловина
на 25-30 метрів у дворі.
Наша Утконосівка перейшла нещодавно на
«Примадонну». Це сорт із «носиками».
Усюди — в Одесі, Києві,
Миколаєві і в Херсоні —
усі питають про помідори з «носиком».
По суті, це другий урожай.
Ось ці помідори вже закінчуються,
а потім вони починають
рости по-новому.
І ростуть до ось такої висоти.
Ми починаємо збирати їх у вересні-жовтні.
Хороші виростають.
Це важка праця.
У нас на двох 3 тисячі кущів.
Забагато для двох.
Але якщо б у нас не було городу,
то і грошей не було б.
Напевне, вся Утконосівка скаже:
«Дякую за те, що є город».
Здебільшого час іде саме на теплиці.
Бо якщо занедбати, то вже
ніякого врожаю не буде.
У цій теплиці тисяча кущів.
А загалом ми вирощуємо 7500 кущів.
У другий оберт у нас огірки.
Ще коли були дідо з бабою вони
вирощували десь по 500 кущів просто для себе.
[Олександр Гергишан
Житель Утконосівки]
Потім побачили, що самі
вже стільки не з'їдають
і їх необхідно кудись реалізовувати.
Тож почали возити по всьому СНД.
Наш основний ринок збуту — це Одеса.
Ми судимо по Одесі.
Якщо є попит, то ціна нормальна.
Нема попиту — ціна падає.
На сьогодні ціна в селі —
20 гривень за кілограм.
В Одесі — 27 гривень.
Різниця в 7 гривень
трохи та й відчувається.
А завтра не знаю, яка буде ціна.
Вона змінюється кожного дня.
Скажімо так, помідори — це найбільш
копітка робота, але з хорошою віддачею.
У кожному домі є теплиці.
Більша чи менша — це вже хто
яку може собі дозволити.
У селі небагато господарств,
які використовують опалення.
Може, 25-30.
Решта не опалюють, а вирощують.
Люди збирають від 20 до 100 коробок.
А то і більше.
Усі вирощують томати для продажу.
Дехто має 20 тисяч кущів,
хтось — 10 тисяч.
У нас тільки 5 тисяч.
Спочатку були дерев'яні теплиці,
потім перейшли на оці металеві.
[Галина Михайлова
Жителька Утконосівки]
Тут, звичайно, набагато краще,
бо вище, більше повітря,
більше світла — а це те,
що потрібно помідорам.
Дуже часто погодні умови впливають
і на врожай, і на те, як вони розвиваються.
Якщо капуста витримує навіть
до -15 градусів морозу,
то помідор зазнає дуже великого стресу.
Він замерзає та й по всьому.
Ось це сорт «Примадонна».
Він характерний тим,
що має ось такі пухирчики.
До речі, по всій Україні дуже
цікавляться цими помідорами.
Вони відрізняються від турецьких помідорів, —
не кажучи вже про смакові якості, —
тим, що вони з отаким пухирчиком.
І всі вже розуміють,
що це утконосівські помідори.
Ми — молдовани, що мешкають в Україні.
Зараз є школи з навчанням
молдавською мовою.
Останнім часом, якщо є два
паралельних молдавських класи,
то третій — український.
Молдавська мова — рідна мова,
однак Україна — це Батьківщина.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Андрій Рогозін]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Blooms Corda, Tik Tu, Marsbeing]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]